good morning John a couple of weeks ago
you and I spent a little bit of time
kayaking around a huge lake that
seemingly impossibly is in the middle of
a desert
and indeed Lake Powell is not natural it
is the reservoir formed by Glen Canyon
Dam now there's a pretty good chance you
don't know much about this the second
largest man-made lake in America about
the tremendous feats of engineering and
human labor required to get it up and
keep it up as well as it's fraught
environmental legacy contentious past
and limited future I didn't really feel
like mentioning any of this while we
were enjoying it but the fight that led
to the creation of Lake Powell in some
ways created the modern environmental
movement and led to some aspects of that
movement that I don't love this marvel
of humanity's ability as well as our
folly is kind of one of my greatest
internal debates made real so I wanted
to talk about that up into the 1960s
dams were a big win for pretty much
everyone especially in the arid
Southwest us first beautiful man-made
Lakes stocked with bass cave fun easy
recreational opportunities to millions
of people while getting into deep hidden
canyons can be all but impossible for a
hiker motoring your boat into one is
just a few gallons of gas away second
the tremendous water pressure that
builds up behind tall dams like Glen
Canyon Dam is also harnessed for energy
at peak enough to power two million
homes without any carbon dioxide or
other emissions and most importantly the
Colorado River is a temperamental Beast
a lot of water flows through the
Colorado River but season to season and
even year to year you never really know
if it's gonna be there when you need it
to flush toilets or irrigate your crops
if states in the southwest we're gonna
be able to grow their economies and
populations they needed a stable source
of water and protection from massive
floods hoover dam of course created lake
mead in the 1930s but a number of other
sites for dams became viable as
technology progressed and the need for
water increased three sites for large
water storage projects included Echo
Park which would have flooded parts of
Dinosaur National Monument Bridge Canyon
which would have flooded parts of the
Grand Canyon and Glen Canyon the fight
between the Sierra Club and the
Department of the Interior of these dams
is stuff of environmental legend and I
encourage you to read about this era
it's fascinating but in the end bridge
Canyon and Echo Park were spared lake
powell was the price this fight not only
spawned much of the modern
environmental movement it also placed it
within a frame that I personally find
myself frustrated with sometimes one of
nature versus humans and our technology
like the fact that we can see these
canyons carved by the Magnificent
unstoppable power of this tremendously
unstable river system and think hey we
should control that is simultaneously
the height of human effort and the
height of human folly I look at this dam
and I think humans are so freakin
amazing
and also so freakin stupid and indeed
these days much of lake powell water is
lost to evaporation water that would
maybe otherwise make it to the sea to
nourish the Gulf of California's Delta
the Colorado River almost always runs
dry by the time America is done with it
now it has met the ocean just once in
the last 20 years and that's just the
start of Lake Powell problems fast
flowing rivers carry sediment but when
it hits the reservoir the water slows
down and the sediment falls out canyons
are now filling with mud as is the area
behind the dam in 100 to 150 years the
sediment will clog the outflow valves
and there will be no way to generate
electricity from the dam and 700 years
without some intervention the reservoir
will completely fill with mud these days
drought has brought the reservoir down
to just fifty percent of capacity and
there are fears that it will get much
worse and yet that's far from the most
severe possible problem which is what
happens when a dam exceeds a hundred
percent of capacity we saw this this
year when the Oroville dam nearly failed
when its spillway began to wash away and
it happened at Glen Canyon in 1983 due
to huge rains dams upstream dumped so
much water into Lake Powell that it kept
rising even after all valves were opened
the spillway began to wash away leaving
a 30 foot deep 80 foot wide hole in the
bedrock of the dam at times like those I
am reminded of the seemingly innocuous
phrase what goes up must come down
someday there will be no dam at Glen
Canyon and we can only hope that when
that happens we do it on purpose
and yet I come to love this dam I love
that I can kayak through those canyons I
love that these people have the beach
that they can go to and fish to catch I
often see the environmental movement
belittle the kinds of fun these people
enjoy the jet skis and the motor boats
and the imagining of nature is something
that exists just to serve humanity the
environmental movement I think can go
too far into imagining
humanity or at least those willfully
ignorant humans as nothing but a blight
on the perfection of nature sometimes
this goes so far as to imagine all
technology as a step in the wrong
direction as if the only way out of this
mess is backward but I cannot abide that
I am in love with nature and I am in
love with humans I won't go so far as to
say that we are natural because while we
are we are also much more and also
sometimes I think less I want Glen
Canyon to be a natural unaltered
ecosystem but I also want people to be
able to enjoy Lake Powell part of being
human is being able to want
contradictory things but I have been
thrilled to watch especially over the
last decade as technology has come to be
seen more as a tool for the protection
of the environment than for its
destruction these large scale
engineering projects that destroyed
natural environments set up a dichotomy
that's now being dismantled by electric
cars and solar panels and LED light
bulbs but there are still times when I
have to excitedly marvel at these
amazing feats of human ingenuity while
also kind of wishing they didn't exist I
disagree with me sometimes and
especially in this particular moment in
history when we are also convinced of
our own rightness and righteousness I
need opportunities to confront admit and
accept that more than ever John I'll see
you on Tuesday while I was researching
this video I came across two documentary
films that the US government made about
Glen Canyon Dam one about the
construction and one about the repair
after the floods in the 1980s and I
found them both fascinating to watch and
if you are the kind of person would like
to watch those I've uploaded them
unlisted The Blob with this channel and
you can do that by clicking on either of
these links here okay bye